das sind wirklich absolut spektakuläre
fotos die wir hier heute zeigen können
und laut experten und expertinnen
meinungen zeigen sie mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit leben auf dem mars
sind wirklich fotos der ein bisschen den
atem stocken lassen denn sie zeigen
dinge die nur mit außerirdischen leben
erklärt werden können und demnach hatte
sich bereits in den nasa rovern
ausgebreitet klicks um science-fiction
gibt es täglich faszinierendes science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
ja und wenn man sich die fotos ansieht
dann ist es zum einen etwas beklemmend
auf einem fremden planeten strukturen zu
sehen die wirklich lebendig zu sein
scheinen und zum anderen auch
faszinierend und es ist zudem absolut
beeindruckend wie viele wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen in diesen fotos
tatsächlich lebensform entdecken fast
alle 70 forscherinnen und forscher die
sich diese fotos angesehen haben sahen
eine hohe wahrscheinlichkeit dass es
sich um leben handeln müsse auf den
fotos sind zum einen strukturen zu
erkennen die nur schwer anders als mit
einer lebensform zu erklären sind und
zum anderen wiederum sehr an
lebensformen hier auf der erde erinnert
zum beispiel auf diesen fotos sind
formen zu sehen die am pilz erinnern die
nase hält zwar auch hämatit für mögliche
mineral das ausreißen und sauerstoff
besteht also ein oxid doch ein weiteres
bild oder genauer zwei bilder lassen an
dieser these extrem zweifeln hier ist
nämlich sogar wachstum zu entdecken auf
den ersten blick haben diese beiden
bilder nur wenig miteinander zu tun
wenn man sich aber an den zahlen
orientiert und sie übereinander legt
wird es pukki dann ist sogar wachstum zu
erkennen die kugeln wachsen sogar
während drei maß tagen und es entstehen
auch noch neue das ist mega verblüffend
aber warum ist diese studie bisher kaum
bekannt entdeckt hat sie ronnie bless
vom youtube kanal raumzeit block der
zukunft wir von zeit verfolgen ja immer
die neuere
publikationen zum thema astrobiologie
daserste.de journalist ein ganz
renoviertes fachblatt und dort haben wir
den aufsatz entdeckt der ist schon ne
weile verfügbar aber jetzt ist er als
preview gegangen und die mehrheit der
experten und der die touren hat
zugestimmt dass der artikel
veröffentlicht wird und bei 70 experten
aus den bereichen astrobiologie und
biologie da waren dann auch hier der
meinung da kann man in dem fall
definitiven video zu machen
das ist ein ganz spannende thematik ein
wenig beängstigend wird es dann aber
auch wenn man sieht wie diese strukturen
von den mars rover der nasa besitz
ergriffen haben denn eigentlich ist es
unter den bedingungen auf dem markt
unmöglich dass etwas sich dort in den
rohren ablagert außer ja außer es ist
eine lebensform denn oxidieren kann
nichts in der marsatmosphäre und so sind
diese bilder mega verblüffen sie zeigen
hier eine ablagerung die sich zwischen
soul 2218 und so 2813 am mars rover
opportunity gebildet hat so entsteht für
master- oder hier beim rover curiosity
sie zeigen wie sich zwischen den mars
tagen soll 51 und so 1089 ablagerungen
im rover bilden was kann das sein
außer mit lebenden organismen ist das
eigentlich nicht erklärbar weitere
bilder von cork city sind noch
beeindruckender hier ist das innere
komplett verändert es ist absolut
rätselhaft oder eben nur mit
biologischen strukturen erklärbar was
könnte den rover so befallen haben und
ausschließlich innen für solche
veränderungen gesorgt haben an einem
stein auf dem mars wurden in einem genau
so geschützten bereich solche
veränderungen von experten und
expertinnen halten pilze oder flechten
für deutlich wahrscheinlicher als alles
andere also leben gibt es leben also auf
dem mars es ist ein weiteres puzzlestück
dass die wahrscheinlichkeit steigen
lässt und was ich an dieser studie so
spannend findet sie tendiert schon sehr
zu außerirdischen leben also die
wissenschaftler und wissenschafter
präferieren leben als erklären und ich
sehe hier genauso den punkt den
professoren loeb bei uns bei pixum im
interview zur humor dem interstellaren
objekt anführt wenn das mögliche als
lösung ausscheidet bleibt nur noch das
unmögliche
obwohl vielleicht ist eben leben im
weltall gar keine ausnahme und dann wäre
dieser fund eben gar nicht so
außergewöhnlich wie wir heute noch
glauben noch mehr zu diesem thema gibt
es hierbei raumzeit lockt der
zukunft draufklicken unbedingt anschauen
und natürlich unbedingt raumzeit werk
der zukunft abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran